[Musique]
bonsoir
vous ne vous êtes n'ont trompé ni de
chaînes ni de jeu ce sont bien les
chiffres et les lettres vous êtes bien
sur antenne 2 nous avons quelque peu
changé de look parce que peut-être que
c'est le printemps il fallait un certain
rajeunissement alors à manger à moi
décidé de apporté quelques modifications
à ce jeu vous allez voir elles sont très
simples surtout dans le décor et puis je
vais vous présenter quelqu'un qui va
dorénavant remplacer joe frachon qui
chez lui d'ailleurs que je salue mon
petit jo toutes nos amitiés c'est une
jeune femme c'est une jeune femme que
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir je
vous demande d'applaudir d'ailleurs ça
va le mettre en confiance
elle s'appelle ariel c'est bien ça ariel
boulin prat exactement ariel je n'aurais
pas je ne vais pas vous demander votre
achat ne se fait pas
vous avez quand même métier je suppose
oui je suis professeur de lettres de
lettres classiques donc normalement les
lettres vous connaissez je ne connais
pas tout mais je vais faire de mon mieux
ayel nous accueillons avec plaisir dans
cette émission je pense que le public va
faire de même pas trop le trac ça va ça
va alors on va faire comme sur une
chaîne concurrente et néanmoins et demi
voilà je vous emmène jusqu'à votre table
vous retrouvez le prochain candidat et
bertrand soyez sages avec lui un c'est
pas le genre de la maison bien mâcher
rivette chance d'être à vos côtés
et moi je me retrouve devant mon petit
pupitre ce qui va me permettre d'avoir
une position assise enfin dans cette
émission nous retrouvons bien entendu
les candidats et la seule modification
importante à part le décor au fort
finalement les minimes il faut que vous
la disent quand même les candidats
n'auront plus et d'ailleurs vous aussi
vous n'aurez plus que 40 secondes
l'autre 45 secondes pour réfléchir et
vous êtes devenu tellement fort qu
armand jammot a décidé que 40 secondes
c'était tout à fait suffisant j'espère
que vous allez vous y faire très vite
messieurs bonjour monsieur baher et
monsieur labidoire mais c'est bien vous
êtes là pour la quatrième fois oui c'est
cela trois victoires mais c'est bien
entendu pour la première comment ça va
est ce que cette nouvelle disposition
géographique vous gêne ou tout va bien
après l'émission et mâcha leur la
chaleur que je dégageais ça vous gêne
pas un but en soi c'est pas
indispensable et bien voilà c'est la vie
douaron choisi c'est entre
perth et avoue viser la victoire
1re 4e 2e 4e 3e troisième
set 25 cents 7 10 3
[Musique]
mais c'est l'âme s'il vous plaît ne
manifeste pas sa joie ni son savoir
[Musique]
fin des 40 secondes vous avez maintenant
un chronomètre à vue mais c'est les
victoires votre résultat c'est trois
fois mieux
cette fois 107-100 plus 3,63
et at il des gens qui l'ont trouvé dans
la salle
oui eh bien vous lever le doigt vous le
dites car dorénavant nous avons fils
vient vers vous avec un micro monsieur
voilà
700 noms ne seront pas excusé à
quelqu'un d'autre alors quelqu'un
d'autre la virginie où sophie quelqu'un
d'autre walt
3 x 10 30 30 mois 25 5 7 mois 5,2 et 700
plusieurs c'est rendu qu'on
applaudissait le sien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous passons tous normalement là rien
n'a changé et que monsieur baher et les
lettres france and her consonnes et
voyelles à consonnes des voyelles une
consonne b voyelles à consonnes air
et voyelles eux
[Musique]
super cette lettre accuse monsieur
labidoire
bardot
brd eux a eu
bardot alors c'est pas brigitte oui tout
à fait c'est très bon il s'agit d'une
courte plancher en bois servant au
recouvrement d'une toiture c'est un
élément toiture connaissez ce mot ariel
pas moi oui au collège quand on n'a ni
tué ni ardoise on prend un bardeau voilà
il y avait il à dit va être parce que
iliad a peu parlé maintenant qu'est ce
qui avait fait défaut garder à wemmel
est bonne elle est bonne la petite
yvette
et les sept autres nous trois et nouveau
tous absolument 7 à 6 monsieur labidoire
les lettres consonnes n consonnes s
voyelles une voyelle
consonnes des consonnes elle voyait à
voyelles et consonnes
elle
[Musique]
ok
mais c'est la victoire
109 5 6 t-shirt vert des délais d eux l
aps et oui bien sûr de délai
aucun problème
parce qu'il y avait mieux la salle
personne non
score 13 à 6 ce sont les chiffres pour
monsieur bercé certaine élite seconde
premières secondes premières secondes
deuxième temps vous aider à mater
chipant dans ce marché mais victor
maintenant je compare le
4-2-4 50 1 6
577 1
ans
[Musique]
offrant
à
alors que nous dit bien que l'audi
monsieur baer 576 c'est vrai il a bien
marqué c'est bon les 50 plus de égale
52,6 plus capucins égalent 11
59 euros égal 572 572 plus 4576 est ce
qu'il ya un 77 dans la salle
non non ils nous ont essentiellement les
jeunes filles préposé au micro donc plus
rien à faire 19 à 6 monsieur bara une
petite avance pour le moment on enchaîne
avec monsieur la vidéo arts et lettres
consonnes et voyelles
et consonnes
ses voyelles et consonnes
j'y voyais l eau
consonnes m
consonne elle
while i
[Musique]
m
voilà mes frères je vous écoute
votre frère c'est mon frère c'est vous 5
5 pas mieux crème le crem
non non pas les passants micro mais si
vous avez des jeunes filles qui sont à
votre disposition j'ose dire nous pas
tous en même temps quelqu'un lève le
doigt et on vient le voir voilà monsieur
au premier rang
morcelé mais si je l'aimais mais mon
seul et merci beaucoup monsieur vous
venez d'où monsieur vous venez de voir
d'où venez vous monsieur pour nous voir
premier sur scène ça va c'est pas trop
loin très bien
19 à 11
c'est un monsieur baer pour les lettres
consonnes
des consonnes
et voyelles
t&e
consonnes
f1 voyelles aux
consoles car voyelles à
consonnes
elle et voyelles et eau
[Musique]
oui
voilà puisque j'ai aussi la possibilité
de copier maintenant je peux vous dire
qu'il va te plaît il n'a strictement
rien trouvé me ce qui est rare que si le
barça me c'est vrai oui si la trahissent
pas mieux fatal fatale a été lent de
foot us c'est ça oui très bien
tiens tiens tiens les applaudissements
25 ans monsieur labidoire les chiffres
premières secondes deuxième seconde
troisième la seconde
[Musique]
neuf 9 10
25 5 6
[Musique]
à
top je lui dois
680 et vous monsieur meyer 689 alors
c'est tabou sans problème 10 +9 +9 égale
28-28 faut 25 700 ch + 5 11 700 - 11 689
très bien
quelqu'un qui soufflait brasse avec
bertrand l'a sûrement tel de données non
moi je ne voulais pas et personne
d'autre ariel vous l'avez de par contre
en chiffres alors ça bien en faire déjà
une très belle ça va très très vite
alors 31 11 monsieur
monsieur bart
consonnes et consonnes n voyelles et
consonnes
elle voyelles et consonnes
et voyelles
une consonne m
voyelles eux
[Musique]
résultat de monsieur baer silat racisme
monsieur la vidéo a pas mieux tu meurs
tu meurs
mais oui mais oui mais oui j'entends
je pose donc ses ventes nettes reculent
menteur menteur oui et obtenant lenteur
37 à 11 monsieur labidoire
consonne voyelle
achats aux consoles aime ma voyelles à
on sonne b consonnes elles
consomment ces consonnes f voyelles
[Musique]
mais si la victoire 105 monsieur maher
faut quand même focal la
démo facile ah
oui je ne sais pas s'il y avait mieux
fait dans la salle non il semblerait pas
besoin manifeste quand ils ont eu un
16-16 à 37 et c'est à monsieur ben amer
pour les chiffres 2nde 1ère seconde
troisième
seconde
5 8 8 1 1 3
[Musique]
où
voilà fin des 40 secondes résultats
du bayern sans 54 54 nous quand les
bombes bonne chose
un lien de plus 8 10 x 2 15 150 plus 858
eh bien on sait que ce soit l'émission
c'est une bonne opération devient de
réaliser monsieur labidoire qui était un
peu en retard le score est temps
maintenant de 37 à 24 ans sa soeur en
faveur de sévères mais comme vous le
savez cela ça n'a pas changé il y a
toujours une deuxième manche dans les
chiffres et lettres
bertrand assez rapidement si vous avez
un petit club qu'une annonce je crois
pour un tournoi qui a lieu alors cette
adresse s'adresse aux jeunes de 12 à 18
ans inclus qui habite dans la région de
versailles juste en dessous 12 à 18 ans
oui vous programme non vous êtes en
dessous il n'avait que 11 ans c'est vrai
c'est le dimanche 16 mars à 10 heures du
matin au centre d'animation pour
chaudfontaine qui se trouve 55 rue
rémois versailles pour chaudfontaine les
inscriptions c'est auprès de monsieur
olivier sur le monsieur olivier sur nous
l'avons vu à anti vous vous en souvenez
le téléphone de monsieur sol c'est le 30
21 84 85 ou le 39 51 54 89 voilà je
crois qu'il faisait partie du club de je
ne sais plus quoi yvette ce saule
versailles
c'est elle que tout est clair oui vous
allez on va me le demande je pense pas
que ça passe un moment important deux
bateaux petit mot d'ariel comment ça
s'est passé ariel pour la première fois
la mer relativement bien mais bon
j'espère que
j'aurai à mesure des émissions la
détente viendra gg sera quelqu'un qui
avait jamais fait télévision que vous en
pensez vous débrouille pas mal je trouve
vous êtes un tel changement vers le dis
merci et à toute heure
[Musique]